okay hi great that's great hi I'm Ashley
McCallum nice to meet you all
I'm general manager of tasty which is
the food studio at BuzzFeed great great
reactions so far so why don't we just
get into it so how many of you it's kind
of hard to see but how many of you know
tasty give me a raise a show of hands
awesome great so how many of you have
actually made a tasty recipe at home
show of hands okay so that's about what
I would expect so usually our research
says that about 90% of people in the
room have heard of tasty and about 50%
of those people have actually made a
recipe at home so LA market doing okay
great so a lot of the women on the stage
will talk tonight about challenges they
have had as a result of being a woman in
the workplace I have had my fair share
of those challenges but tonight I am
going to talk about something different
which is being the youngest person in
every room so I'm 30 and I have often
felt insecure about my age and so
hopefully tonight we can you can end
leave with a little bit of a different
perspective on having experience or not
having experience so I'm gonna kick it
off with a story of how I got my first
job in media this is kind of a story
that'll never leave me fortunately or
unfortunately so I grew up in South
Carolina with no experience in media no
connections but when I decided I wanted
to be a medium I knew I had to be
creative so I flew myself to New York
City to visit a friend who was studying
studying there and I thought to myself
if I'm gonna be physically near these
media companies I should be able to get
a job right it just was very intuitive
to me this was like before social media
I just I couldn't go to New York City
and not leave with a job so I'm gonna
show you a photo but I'm gonna caveat it
to say that I asked the event organizers
if I could show a photo and they said
nope there are no visuals no slides but
I asked for an exception and if you're
following along this is the trend for me
so will I'll show you this photo
may be that you
I knew who's who one day we'll show you
a photo oh there it is okay so that was
ten years ago
I showed up to the Today Show yeah so
that was ten years ago I showed up to a
Sean Kingston concert anyone remembers
him very popular ten years ago and
that's a sign you can read that says
this southern belle wants to be NBC's
next summer intern and so I held it up
during commercial breaks exciting care
about being on TV I wanted to producers
to see it and it worked so the executive
producer of the show at the time Jim
Bell came down and met me and he asked
for my resume and cover letter and I got
the job which is kind of crazy and
please don't do that it's like super
stalker to do that now you should just
like tweet at someone like don't show up
that's super weird now but I was too
inexperienced to know that it was creepy
and I was too inexperienced to know what
was possible what was impossible and so
not having experience and just having
confidence was the thing that really
helped me in that situation so let's
flash forward to today
it's a present day so I've been a
BuzzFeed for six years which is like dog
years for BuzzFeed it's like I've been
there forever and so I moved to LA a
couple years ago and started running
tasty which is this massive success for
BuzzFeed them had a lot of fun doing it
we have some tasty producers in the room
I don't know where they're sitting where
are they right over here okay you guys
know the hands and the tasty video it's
like they're right there put your hands
up Diana and Julia okay just two of the
hands are you moisturized you guys are
good okay thanks for coming by the way
so tasties had an incredible rise and
all the fact that all of you know in
this room is it's like pretty amazing
but it became very quickly a crowded
marketplace so if you know how you
scroll through your facebook feed and
everything kind of looks like a tasty
video like you like don't even know you
watching anymore
you end up in this like vortex of food
videos or like something that's top down
and fast that's because a lot of people
copied us really fast
and so usually copycats take a long time
but this time for whatever reason within
a year we had tons of copycats entire
companies sprung up really just to copy
our strategy and copy our format so I
knew that we had to provide more value
particularly to our advertising partners
there's no way we could just have a
massive commoditized crowded marketplace
and continue to remain remain on top um
so trying to figure out where was tasty
gonna provide more value so I started
looking at our editorial operation and
trying to understand the audience more
and what I saw was that within hours
after posting a video our audience was
uploading photos of them actually making
it so I asked you earlier how many of
you actually made recipe people were
watching a tasty video getting in their
car driving in the grocery store buying
the ingredients and coming home and
making it for their friends and family
now maybe that seems intuitive but with
digital publishers we've always kind of
been bucketed as top of funnel I don't
how many of you work in advertising okay
some of you so right so we've always
been bucking as top of funnel mid funnel
but the idea of tasty or big mass media
company being able to drive sales it was
totally counterintuitive by our
editorial work was indicating that we
could so last summer I held a an
off-site for all the people who work on
tasty advertising business and we had
talked about all the normal stuff for
new holes and accounts and all that
stuff and then I had a 30-minute session
where I said tasty the full funnel
advertising partner question mark and so
I got up in front of the room and I said
hey guys like I have you know I have
this hunch that I think that we can
actually play in this space but I wanted
all of us to be aligned on this thing
that we're building are we building a
full funnel advertising solution and I
got head nods for most of the people the
room these two old dudes two senior men
in the back of the room who immediately
shot me down and then said no way you
will never compete in the space we
cannot prove bottom of funnel sales
their entire company's Google has spent
the better part of the last two decades
proving a last click attribution what is
BuzzFeed gonna do like how are we gonna
prove this I took this on as a personal
challenge
and so I had an unwavering vision for
tasty that we could do this even though
it didn't make sense that I would not
listen to two senior men who spent their
entire lives and advertising and I was
fairly new to advertising and so the
fact that I didn't listen to them
doesn't make a ton of sense but I was
very focused I had this clear vision for
what we could do that was nine months
ago in two weeks we're rolling out
research that proves that we can drive
sales with three of our biggest clients
today we launched a 90 SKU cookware
bakeware line and every Walmart store in
America as a result of us being able to
drive sales and in thank you keep it
coming just and in two weeks I will be
announcing at the biggest CPG
advertising conference in the country
tasties full funnel advertising solution
in two weeks so thank you so the point
of that is to say that you should
challenge this convention that
experience more experience means you're
more qualified or you're smarter or
you're better because if I listen to the
people with all the experience we would
have never pushed the boundaries so when
you are the most junior person in the
room and you have an idea that's not
clear or maybe or it's not clear that
it'll work
you should just remember that the most
senior people in the room are probably
the ones who made the rules so they're
not gonna be the ones who break them and
so if they made the conventions they
won't ignore them you have to do that
and so you often have to push and you
have to push back and ignore experience
and just focus on your confidence thank
you
[Applause]